[Music]
we have the vote Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell proudly announced a the
Republicans have secured enough support
to pass their sweeping overhaul of our
nation's tax system
Arizona Senator Jeff Flake was the key
holdout but he backed the plan this
afternoon
a final vote could come as early as
tonight or even tomorrow what's your
take what's your take on this right well
first of all this is great news not the
best bill but this is you know you can't
let the perfect be the enemy of the good
I think that you know we've seen a lot
of talk from the Bannen side of the
Republican Party and others like throw
these bums out let's start you let's get
new blood I think this makes the case
for why someone like Mitch McConnell who
understands how to navigate the
legislative process can cobble these
votes together this was not easy to do
I predict also that if they made the
right changes we may see that it will
not go to conference that the house may
just vote on what they have there
because everyone's afraid of going back
to the Senate where it's it's tough to
get those votes so I think you might you
might see the House vote on the Senate
bill as is Dana and that's I think it's
possible because I think they don't want
to talk about it anymore
yes they just want to get it I just want
to be able to go home and say we did
this and then I think that what's will
happen is that the Republicans who used
to be concerned about the deficit will
hope that the economic growth is what
they hope it will be and then the then
basically the Republicans and the
Democrats will have a debate about the
results that's right but I do think they
want to get to yes and get it over with
and and I think that the the results
already of Trump's economic agenda are
doing well I live in in in Wisconsin as
you guys know I have brothers in-laws
and sisters in-laws were small business
owners they can't keep up with the
orders they're turning customers away
they're turning down jobs places that
were the Forgotten America this is world
Wisconsin Donald Trump has a lot of
credibility on economics he went out and
sold this tax plan as it's going to help
I actually you know though I wish it
could have been more bold I was I'm a
big flat tax person I wish we had gone
in that route
look I think that this is a if you're
right I I think it's going to I don't
know anyone who actually understands it
I've talked to a lot of people Hill what
I talked to my accountant what is this
no idea I have really high hopes I mean
there's only really one question from
the last election and that is how do you
save the middle class which is shrinking
and dying younger and believes it's
going to make less than its parents made
it's a disaster and so everything the
federal government do does has to be
focused on fixing that one problem right
and I really hope this bill does that I
don't well I guess we'll see I guess I
am very bothered that that's not obvious
going into this but when you bring
company when you let that money come
back overseas and you encourage and
incentivize companies to start building
factories in America that does make a
difference in companies making more
money than any time in history and we
still have persistently high permanent
unemployment like 100 million people and
wages are still stuck so that's true so
I agree with you Tucker which is a
rarity America because I do think that
this bill is missing how you deal with
the middle class and everything in this
bill that was taken out of it all the
things they repealed were things that
benefited middle class like for example
you know being able to deduct your
student loan interest rate but Greg your
turn oh thanks this is tax reform the
way shaking up a can of coke is cope
reform this is not an overhaul whoever
wrote sweeping reform needs their head
examined this is this is more liberal
than it is conservative know is the top
one percent provides 40 percent of the
federal income tax revenue is this
helping them or hurting them it's
hurting them I think the corporate part
was fine I'm for that the individual
thing is a mess it's a mess in trying to
sugarcoat it is hilarious good luck but
it sucks and I think you're I agree with
you it's like I talk to people and I say
I said it's like trying to untangle your
iPhone earbuds when you're trying to do
you're trying to go like what and then
you have to do this and then wait then
you do this so we're gonna give you this
but then we're gonna take this back oh
no but then you can have that that's
what this is we want something simple as
you said in the break something bold we
have an opportunity to do something bold
we talked a great
we talked a great game for decades and
then we get the opportunity and what do
we do this
oatmeal this bland pale oatmeal but you
can't you can't touchdown you cannot do
the bold reform that you and me and all
of us here I count him out okay fine but
you cannot do that without the Senate
changing the rules because they have
come to the table thank you if you came
to the table and work with the Democrats
and Republicans you could pass real
reforms Ronald Reagan did it in 280